hey guys we're back a Roseanne's kitchen
table and I'm pretty sure you know this
lovely young lady that I have sitting
with me today hey miss Ana Kasparian
right here going on guys you know we're
just having some coffee shooting the
[ __ ] and the year is just about up i
think by the time we post this it'll be
up tomorrow so you gotta watch quick and
we want to talk about some of the
biggest stories of the year and the
things that we were talking about all
year but not just kind of recapping them
which everyone knows all the story but
sort of how we as newsy people what are
we re news people yeah we're doozy
people renew Z people uh how they sort
of affected us and how we dealt with the
coverages stuff yeah so I thought a good
one to start with because I think it was
probably the most over-the-top coverage
uh is the plane but rats are between i
almost said Ebola there cuz that I
pretty over-the-top coverage too we'll
get to that effect but the plane the
first missing plane barest missing plane
from Malaysia yeah so now we had a
second one which apparently as of this
morning I guess has been found or at
least some wreckage is Macau but the
first missing plane for Malaysia that
never got found right and CNN basically
devoted two months of coverage to it how
did you handle it as a as a news person
had you know the coverage i was just
endless how did you so i don't know if
this is a bad thing to say but i want to
be as candid as possible the audience I
there are some stories where you do get
emotionally invested and then there's
some stories that might be very tragic
but you don't feel emotionally invested
and this was a story where I didn't have
any emotional investment and so whenever
we reported on it I made sure to just
give the facts and anytime there was any
pressure to give my opinion about it was
difficult yeah because when you're not
emotionally invested in this particular
story you don't really know what to say
it's a missing plane so all you really
can do is give the audience the
information and then if they want to
speculate sure but speculation was
rampant yes so we'll wait we'll talk
about speculation set but the emotional
investment thing I think is kind of
interesting cuz it was obviously a huge
tragedy hundreds of people dead and or
missing it's you know we still don't
know what happened but I I agree it
didn't hit me like people were already
joking about it within 24 hours you know
they say comedies tragedy plus time but
in this case it was like the joking
started immediately and then when this
plan this past week immediately the
jokes kicked in so why do you think it
didn't hit you
emotionally you know first of all let me
say I don't know if I agree with people
joking around about it it was still a
tragedy I feel terrible for the victims
and the victim's family members but at
the same time I I can't really explain
why i didn't feel emotionally invested
it maybe it was because you know there
weren't people that I could relate to i
don't know right you think it would
actually you would probably felt
differently if it was an American plane
let's airplane or left America maybe
like I don't these are all the pieces
that like I I think that doing this job
and this is a difficult thing to admit
has really desensitize me to stories
where deaths are involved yeah um there
are some cases where injustice is also
involved with death and that's when I do
become emotionally invested but in this
case it was like I mean so we've covered
so many stories about people dying in
war and so many people dying of chemical
attacks in Syria and it's like uh
unfortunately you do become desensitized
to it and I hate that about myself that
I've become that person yeah and
actually almost everyone that I've been
doing these with we've talked about just
sort of overload news and like only
absurd amount of brain space for us
anyway we actually didn't even cover it
on my show because I knew there was so
much and everyone was joking about CNN
in the black hole theory in blah blah
blah that we just let it go uh so let's
move on to the other one which was so
Ebola I think was the other sort of
media crazy one because we had a good
month where people thought it was going
to be like The Walking Dead you know
like zombies were coming to get us and
now it's kinda just at least for the the
American whatever its kind of fizzled
out yeah it has fizzled out it's amazing
because with news there seems to be like
a flavor of the month and Ebola was
certainly a flavor of the month it's
still a problem in Africa right now but
for some reason journalists have decided
now there are other things to focus on
yeah uh I mean the whole civil unrest in
the United States after Ferguson is
probably one of the reasons why we
shifted our focus right and we all do
one story at a time I know it's a major
problem and we usually focus solely on
America so um but that was another
classic story where there was a lot of
fear-mongering a lot of people who
didn't understand the virus or how it
worked so you know for me as someone in
the media I felt my that my job was to
discredit the fear-mongering that was
out there so people would just calm down
a little bit yeah so you were really
on that with this one I think yeah
trying to get rid of that know when we
covered it on my show I tried to bring
our people that know about science
because I don't know everything about
sides so the other one that I want to
get to is the Cosby thing because as
I've talked about many times Bill Cosby
was my childhood hero I saw Bill Cosby
himself in 1983 seven years old and I
realized I wanted to do comedy uh and
then this story which people had heard
about that's the the fascinating thing
with this one for years people have been
talking about this stuff in these
lawsuits but suddenly Hannibal Buress
does this set in it and then look he's
convicted or in the quarter publican is
a convicted i right right i mean
honestly he is Judd Apatow went after a
bunch of Canadian venues that are still
hosting him for standup yeah and I think
that it's an interesting case because he
hasn't been convicted and he did settle
in 2006 out of court yeah so it's really
difficult for people who really love him
to accept the fact that there's a huge
possibility that he sexually assaulted
or raped uh a lot of these women and
that's exactly how I felt cuz we were
doing these stories and I was physically
like I didn't feel right even talking as
I want to give him the benefit of every
doubt and then at the same point if it
had been some comedian that I didn't
like of course I wouldn't have been
doing that so that's what sort of about
that personal connection that you need
to every story for that one it was very
hard for me two for me to talk about and
also i can understand people who might
hear one or two accusations and
discredit the women right because all
this is a famous person was a lot of
money they're looking for money but
we're talking about more than two dozen
women many of which one absolutely no
money or no you know compensation for
what occurred they just want their story
to get come out there and think about
the type of criticism and the type of
ridicule they have to deal with just
because they're coming forward and
talking about what allegedly happened to
them so uh all you can really do at this
point since he hasn't been convicted and
he's not being tried in a court of law
is speculate as to whether or not he did
it but i would say that i'm leaning in
the direction of he did it yeah and we
even talked when we did this on the
young turks we talked about the
speculation and i don't like to do it
but you know there's some level of you
gotta kind of just
about these things and you know make
sure people understand that he hasn't
been convicted and all I said anyway so
those were three of the big stories
we're going to do another segment on a
couple others what do you think did we
do okay job covering it let us know